many story tonight concerns government
sports for nerds these days we are all
focused on the presidential race the
biggest most prominent office in all of
government but I would like to talk
about the opposite of that one of the
smallest and most obscure forms of
government special districts that's
right tonight we are talking about
special taxing districts so hello people
watching for the first time because of
our Trump piece and also I presume
goodbye goodbye thanks for checking in
but just so you know special districts
are small units of government with the
power to take tax dollars to do one
specific thing you've probably heard of
a five district or a water district but
they can be set up for almost any
purpose and there are way more of them
than you think special districts over
the past half-century have really
proliferated to the point that we have
about 40,000 of them in the country now
and they account for about a hundred
billion dollars of spending a hundred
billion dollars a year that is sixteen
billion more than Russia spends on its
military and when you include school
districts special districts are the most
common form of local governments in the
country and that's crazy it's like
finding out the highest-paid athlete in
the world is Harold I mean who the
is Harold what sport does he play why
don't people talk about this all the
time how am I only hearing about
Harold's now you're making me feel a
fool special districts are so ubiquitous
and sometimes have so little
accountability states may not even know
how many they have or how much they
spent a few years back Idaho launched an
investigation of special districts with
objective one being identify how many
special districts there are in Idaho and
when Kentucky investigated it order to
found that 40% of its districts that
were required to didn't even file proper
budgets I mean this is this is an
extraordinary mess as one of my good
friends says you can't make this up 2.7
billion dollar system of government
operating because of a lack of oversight
and accountability at almost every level
has been permitted to become a level of
ghost government yes ghost governments
I'm not even the shittiest idea
ghost story I've ever heard a sign of
course from ghost dad and that was a bad
idea before context changed the way we
felt about Bill Cosby having the power
to walk through walls before then it was
a bad idea after it was horrifying but
if you think about it it's a little
weird in a country that talks so much
about government accountability that a
huge amount of our tax dollars go to
fund entities that most of us know
absolutely nothing about you may not
even know how many districts you are
living in right now a school district
may overlap with a park district a water
district your sewer district and so on
such that it wouldn't be at all uncommon
for one person to be finding themselves
within the boundaries of ten or more of
these districts that's right think of a
special district like a cult it can take
your money and you may not even be aware
that you are in one although it is worth
remembering in a special district
allowing the leader to impregnate you is
not mandatory no matter what the guy in
charge of the library district says no
matter what he says with his words or
eyes and if you're thinking we'll look
what difference does it make what
districts I'm in well it can actually
make a big difference one person that we
found paid a thousand dollars as part of
an irrigation special district that he
lives in in north central Phoenix his
neighbor literally across the street is
not a part of that district they're
special district bill was $7.00 1000
versus $7 look the only people who
should be paying a thousand dollars more
than their neighbors across the street
are the who cover every square
inch of their house with Christmas
decorations they should be taxed and
then they should be imprisoned and then
they should be told their lights were
better last year because it's that one
that would hurt them the most that's the
one that would sting
and it is important to note here in
theory and often in practice having
small entities with a single purpose can
be a great idea
take Litchfield New Hampshire in 2007
they chose to create a mosquito control
districts to you know control mosquitoes
it's run by two men who as you will see
from an amazing YouTube video of one of
their public meetings are almost
heartbreakingly conscientious regardless
of the fact that there is no one else in
the room which I'll steam for the Pledge
of Allegiance call the roll
thank you boys cheer mr. otto present
i'm here you have got to admire their
dedication to the rules these two men
are so scrupulous they would sit and a
broken red traffic light for six hours
in the middle of the night red is red we
live in a civilized society red is red
we stay in fact they ran that 43 minute
meeting so meticulously they even took
input from the public with predictable
results any members of the public
wishing to speak
I guess when you're a member of a ghost
government it's only natural your
meetings are going to be attended only
by the ghost public now that that is the
best case scenario and many special
districts are like that chugging along
just fine with no major problems but
some like the Isaacson Municipal Utility
District in Texas are not because an
audit recently discovered $70,000 in
losses and that the district builds
residents for water with a disturbing
consistency we're not all professional
accountants or managers we may not have
looked at things as closely as maybe we
should have I mud has been billed for
thirteen million seven hundred twenty
one two hundred gallons of water every
year for the last six years rain or
drought or weather no change
same number now no charges have been
followed there but that level of
consistency is weird the only time the
exact same amount of water should appear
in a document year after year is in
shambo's writer yeah Shamu gets thirteen
point seven million gallons of water at
his tank at all times and not a drop
less he's a artist I'm obviously
kidding you can keep him in a wading
pool if you want and if you want to
his blowhole that will be an extra 20
the point is thanks for visiting
SeaWorld but but in Kentucky in Kentucky
the lack of supervision led to outright
corruption with over a hundred thousand
dollars being fantastically misspent by
one former assistant fire chief the
report claims the garret volunteer fire
department in Floyd County used taxpayer
money to buy things like flat screen
televisions chewing tobacco and
fireworks investigators say they also
found hundreds of pornographic videos on
department electronics all right all
right porn and chewing tobacco
obviously inappropriate but you know
what really upsets me the most they're
fireworks there are fire department
hearing EMTs have been using their
budget to stage scissor races thank you
natural enemy but that behavior was
nothing compared to what happened in a
fire district in Rhode Island you won't
believe the undercover video we gathered
on the man in charge we spotted him
drinking during the day then driving the
fire department vehicle back to work
we even had him taking the public safety
vehicle to party up on Federal Hill
drinking and apparently smoking
marijuana this is you smoking what looks
to be pot so God maybe you didn't share
the cigar with your friend sir
I don't know that's a cigar yes it is
you know I got to tell you if no one's
gonna buy that I'm pretty sure they'll
definitely buy it um that's a cigar just
like that's flour for when you want to
bake one tiny cookie that's honey for my
tea I use a very specific amount and
that's just some quartz I keep laying
around
I love quartz look corruption is not
unique to special districts there are
clearly problems in all other forms of
government as well but when special
districts only have one job it makes it
all the more noticeable when things go
wrong take Evergreen Park Illinois the
county it scene has four different
mosquito abatement districts to prevent
the spread of West Nile so it had to be
humiliating when this happened the mayor
of West Suburban Evergreen Park came
down with West Nile virus
look merica King West Nile look no one
is expecting a zero percent failure rate
here but if you're surrounded by that
many mosquito abatement districts
shouldn't there at least be agents
willing to take a mosquito for him come
on and one of the most interesting ways
that special districts are different
from any other form of government is how
they can be created seemingly out of
thin air
for instance in Conroe Texas a company
was hoping to create a new neighborhood
on undeveloped land they wanted to form
a special district which can issue bonds
now to do this the law required a vote
but remember no one lived there yet so
guess what they did
when Tim Kellerman saw someone
installing a mobile
next to his house recently he asked them
what's going on he told me is none of my
business this man and his wife moved in
on Monday and signed a nine-month lease
with stingray services after that he
said they're moving out they're the only
two people who can vote on five hundred
million dollars worth of bonds for the
new housing project two people voting
for five hundred million dollars of
bonds and then leaving it's as if in the
Lion King Simba's father looked out over
the plains and said son someday this
will all be someone else's problem and
they both could often never came back
and that whole process is perfectly
legal in fact this wasn't the only place
where stingray services provided what
they called turnkey voter trailer
election services they won't even
advertised on Craigslist with an ad
reading eligible tenants will vote in
and serve as election officials for the
election which takes place in the home
oh that's right you're not just the only
voters you're the election officials and
your trailer is the polling station it
makes you wonder why they didn't just
throw in some ballot
initiatives just for fun oh and on the
motion that Jena start cleaning out her
hairbrush could it starting to
look like we have a cat we seem to be
tied one to one and once once a special
district is created you can be pretty
sure no one is going to be watching what
you do because remember that New
Hampshire video when we found it on
YouTube it had zero views zero meaning
those two guys themselves didn't even
watch it that is anti viral as videos go
and voter accountability is pretty
unlikely - one County in New York found
turnout rates for some special district
elections could be as low as one point
eight percent which might be because
that County held on average one special
district election every ten point nine
business days with not a single one
taking place on Election Day which just
seems inherently suspicious think about
it it would be a bit of a red flag if
someone in your neighborhood offer
children candy every 11 days but never
on Halloween
give you pause for thought and even if
the state government does investigate
special districts may try to blow them
off when that Kentucky auditor started
asking his state's districts about
they're making their information
available to the public he got some
pretty unhelpful responses here's one
direct quote by the way we didn't take
any liberties with these quote this
contains information the public is not
entitled to know this is a good one we
don't want to fill this out because
there are too many crackpots in the
world and my favorite well we just
rather the public contact us directly to
gain information so we know who's asking
what you get the sense that preferred
mode of contact would be an email to
fake email address at gov and and by the
way if after hearing that some
Kentuckians wanted to shut a district
down they might not be able to because
as that order to wrote many types of
districts may continue to exist because
there is not a process for them to be
dissolved there's no way to break them
up they're like styrofoam packing
peanuts or the enduring friendship of
Jimmy Fallon and Justin Timberlake
they'll be with us until the end of time
now to be fair some states are pushing
to reform special districts California
for instance has made them far more
transparent in recent years and as
special districts Association in San
Diego even launched a competition for
school children to create a one-minute
video educating the public about what's
so special about special districts the
deadline was Tuesday and it had a $1,500
top prize and the reason I know that is
we entered with some local school kids
and this is the
these toxoids special districts what
special about them special districts of
small government that collect taxes that
handled one specific service like fight
fire or provide water by fireworks or
smoke cigars special districts are
special because they can receive little
oversight they sometimes got ghost
governments I used to be afraid of those
but now offering girls special districts
can also be very easy to create
sometimes the only people voting for
them are two people in a field and the
middle of nowhere the two people in the
trailer in an empty field
sounds like my younger brother you know
it's true duckling you won't wanted
sometimes special districts aren't so
special though like when the mayor of a
village in a county with for mosquito
spring districts came down with the West
Nile virus that would barely be
acceptable if your tongue we're near the
actual Niles everything you think so
little about you don't even realize
that's not important is to get rid of
them so obviously they would never meet
because that's crossing universes
so to recap special districts save their
money and do whatever they want with it
with little to no consequences what I
grew up I want to be a special district
you